Missions are things we tend to associate with
astronauts. If someone at a party asked you
what you did, and you said you were involved
on a mission of some kind, people would look
at you sort of strangely. But in truth, we’d
all benefit from focusing in on the purpose
of our lives so that we can refer to them
as missions of one kind or another. When the
entrepreneur Elon Musk was at university,
he asked himself very explicitly what his
mission in life would be. He began by wondering
what the world needed most urgently, then
he looked into himself to see what his talents
were and that led him to a list of four possible
missions: space exploration, electric transportation,
Artificial Intelligence and rewriting the
human genome. In the end, Elon Musk chose
the first two. Few of us will ever settle
on missions as mighty as these, but the notion
of having a mission, rather than a mere job
or hobby, remains widely applicable. How,
then, can we learn to adopt the mission mindset?
– Firstly, what matters is to adopt a certain
seriousness about one’s life. The working
bit will only be, at best, 50 years. So the
challenge is around focus: how can one reduce
the range of one’s enthusiasms and see that
having so many interests is half the problem.
Talk of a mission forces us to reduce what
we care about down to just a few very big
things: it privileges precision over breadth.
You give yourself a specific target, aware
of how much energy it will take to reach it.
– Secondly, a mission is about having a
plan; and reducing the amount of times that,
because one has no clear goal, one gets swept
along by the plans of others. – Then again,
a mission is different from an ambition. An
ambition starts with what you want. A mission
centers around what others need. People with
missions may well end up making money and
having status, but that isn’t what led them
to the mission in the first place. Missions
are about the intrinsic worth of tasks. – The
search for a mission requires you to ask:
among all the problems facing humanity, what
are the ones that properly interest me? Be
alive to the small-scale but authentic concerns.
– Having focused on a problem of humanity
that feels right for you, you then need to
take an honest look at your own aptitutes.
What truly are your talents? What can you
contribute? That may require a lot of introspection,
career counselling and experimentation. – Then,
where your skills and aptitudes intersect
with the needs of the world, that is your
distinctive zone: that’s where your mission
lies. – A mission isn’t a mission because
it is grand, but because it is precise. Examples
of modest but crucial missions might be: – a
mission to improve the care that the elderly
receive at the end of their lives – or a
mission to teach children music in an engaging
way – or a mission to get the best pizzas
out to the customers of north Liverpool or
downtown San Diego. – Conceiving of a mission
requires us to throw off an attitude of inner
serfdom, where we imagine that only other
people have the right to plan their lives
– and everyone else must just surrender
to accidents and random whims of employers.
– We can and should all have missions. With
a mission in hand, the next time you’re
at a party, you won’t need to keep the conversation
at the level of where you’re employed, you
can answer with reference to the underlying
logic of what you are up to. You can, with
no space helmet to your name, legitimately
announce that you’re in this earth with
a mission to carry out.
Thank you for watching, liking and subscribing.
If you want more, why not visit us in person and attend a class?
Or take a look at our shop at the link on your screen now.